[موسيقى]
اسرائيل تطلق صراحه كريم يونس اقدم اسير
سياسيه في العالم محكمه الجنايات القاهره
تقضي بحبس منه شلبي وتغريمها الكشف عن
تفاصيل مثيره لشجار وقع بين الامير ويليام
وهارين هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقولها لكم من
قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
بعد ما امضى 40 عاما داخل السجن واعتبر
اقدم سجين سياسيا في العالم اخرجت السلطات
الاسرائيليه عن عميد الاسرى الفلسطينيين
كريم يونس هيئه الاسرى الفلسطينيين اوضحت
ان اسرائيل افرجت عن الاسير يونس البالغ
من العمر 66 عاما افرجت عليهم بشكل مفاجئ
وتركته وحيدا في الشارع دون ايه ما ابلاغ
احد من افراد عائلته معتبره هذا التصرف
محاوله
الحاشد فيما تم اعتقاله في يناير العامه
83 بيتها من بينها الانتماء لحركه فتح
المحظوره انا ذاك وقتل جندي اسرائيلي
في اولى جلساته محاكمه الفنانه منه شلبي
قضت محكمه جنايات القاهره بمعاقبتها
بالحبس سنه مع وقف التنفيذ وتغريمها
10,000 جنيه بتهمه حيازتها مواد مخدره
بقصد التعاطي وسالو اعلان المحليه ذكرت ان
شلبي غابه عن الجلسه بينما حضر عشره
محاميين للدفاع عنها لافته الى ان المحامي
محمد ابو شقه دفع ببطلان اجراءات التفتيش
في مطار القاهره لكونه جرى دون موافقه
الفنانه وعلمها وكانت الاجهزه الامنيه
القت القبض على منا شلبي اثناء عودته من
السفر بحوزتها كميه من المخدرات نهايه
نوفمبر الماضي
مازال الامير هاري يتصدر احاديث وسائل
الاعلام والسوشيال ميديا خصوصا بعد كشفه
تفاصيل مثيره في سيرته الذاتيه المرتقي
بنشرها قريبا حول هجوم تعرض له من قبل
شقيقه الامير ويليام في منزله بلندن عام
التي حصلت على نسخه من السيره الذاتيه
اشارت الى ان ويوم نعتا ميجام ماركل
بالوقحه وصعبه الميراث لتتصاعد حده
المواجهه بين الشقيقين لدرجه انه ويليام
امسك بياقتها ومزق قلادته وطرحه على الارض
ما ادى الى اصابات الاخير في ظهره فيما
ذكره هاري ان شقيقه اعتذر في وقت لاحق عن
تصرفه هذا
عاد اللاعبان الصديقان الفرنسي كلين بابي
والمغربي اشرف حكيمي ليشعل مواقع التواصلي
مجددا بمجموعه صور ظهرها فيها وهما
يتجولان في ساحه تايم سكوير في نيويورك
بشكل تنكريه الصور اظهرت النجمين الدوليين
وهما يغطين وجهيهم وراءسيهما باقنعه
القماشيه اثناء حضورهما عرض الراقصا في
الساحه وذلك كفاديا لتهافت المعجبين
المعجبين عليهما والرغبه في التقاط الصور
معهما وكان ثنائي ظهر مؤخرا وهما يتابعان
مباريات دوري كره السله الامريكيه ضمن
جائزه تستمر لايام قليله
[موسيقى]
وفي خبرنا الاخير نقلت وكاله رويترز عن
مذكره من الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه امازون
عندي جيسي تم ارسالها للموظفين ان الشركه
ستسرح اكثر من ثمانيه عشره الف موظف كجزء
من تخفيض القوى العامله الذي تم الكشف عنه
سابقا جنسيه قال ان قرارات التسريح التي
ستبدا امازون الابلاغ بها في الثامن عشر
من يناير الجاري ستؤثر كثيرا في منظمات
التجاره الالكترونيه
والموارد البشريه التابعه للشركه فيما تصل
التخفيضات الى 6% من القوه العامله في
الشركه العملاقه التي يبلغ قوامها نحو
300,000 عامل
[موسيقى]